Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Surprise!
Today we have a sponsored stream!
Yeah!
So, Bandai asked me to check out the Open Network Test now for Simuality, Echo of Ada.
What is the Open Network Test?
That means any of you guys can join in!
So, another thing that they request... Also, it's a huge challenge.
Shoutout to Bandai for sponsoring for today.
Today might be my... Today's gonna be the last quote-unquote schedule stream before I take a little rest.
I don't know.
I think I'll be taking a little...
a week, a week and a half rest before I come back.
But I still will be doing a Christmas stream and also a... I'll still be doing a Christmas stream and a New Year's countdown stream.
So, don't worry about that.
Right now, after today... On Saturday, I do have an Apex tournament.
So, after today, it's more so like streams will be a little sporadic.
It will be a little bit like guerrilla streams, unannounced stuff.
So, just giving you guys a heads up!
Cause I'm finally gonna take a little bit of a break.
It's been almost a year of me going gas, gas, gas, gas, gas.
I'm finally gonna take... To be fair, I feel like this year, I've taken... When I came back, I have taken a lot of breaks this year compared to the last, you know, three years of streaming.
The last three years of streaming, my breaks were rare.
But I feel like this year, I've definitely taken more breaks than last year.
I think it's because I'm also doing a lot more stuff.
So, I definitely...
I feel like I'm doing a lot more stuff.
And like, so, I do need more breaks just to recharge myself.
Anyway, I fucked myself over tonight... Yesterday night, because I spent the whole night playing Marvel Rivals for seven plus hours yesterday night.
And I went to bed at...
8 AM.
I went to bed at 8 AM.
Maybe I played more than seven... No, I played more than seven hours.
It was like nine hours of Marvel Rivals.
And guess where... And guess where I was at?
With grinding my rank points, I was down a game.
I was one game, three times, in three separate occasions, I was one game away from Grandmaster.
I literally... I got fucked over by several people.
I won't call them out, because you can look them up.
So, I won't call them out, but they know who they are.
I got fucked over by three separate games.
Like, my actual GM rank up game, I... I won't say who they are, because they had TTVs in their name.
So, I can't call them out.
But one of them was a fucking Thor 1 trick.
And I was so mad, because we had this guy on our team, three games in a row.
And then, I was like... And at that point, I was dueling.
And I was like, we have to avoid them.
We've never won with this stupid fucking Thor 1 trick on our team.
And then, so we avoided them.
And then, we got against them.
And then, I was like, if we lose to this guy, we're fucking... I'm done.
I'm done.
I'm so fucking done.
And then, I told my duo, I was like, avoid... I was like, ban Thor.
Ban Thor, so they're absolutely useless.
And then, I was like, type in chat and say, ban Thor.
And then, my duo was like, bro, they're so bad.
It's alright.
We don't need a ban Thor.
They're so fucking bad.
We should have banned Thor.
We should have fucking... We should have banned Thor.
Like, this guy literally would not play anything else but Thor.
Like, the game before I had him with, half our... like, three people in our team was crying at him to fucking swap off Thor.
And was like, please, I'm begging you, please swap off Thor.
We can win this game.
And this guy did not care.
He did not fucking care.
And I was like, ban this guy.
Ban the character.
And my duo, of course, was like, it's alright.
We lost.
We fucking... we lost the game.
I was... I was so... I was so angry.
I... and then... and then... and then I... and then I went to bed.
And I was like... I was like, that was the game.
I decided that I need to stop.
Like, I lost four games in a row with this stupid fucking Thor 1 trick.
It was over.
I couldn't keep going.
I couldn't.
But like, three times, I played... I was... three times, I was one win away from GM.
I was so mad.
I was like, oh my god.
I played, like, more than nine plus hours.
And three fucking times, I was one game away from GM.
Anyway, I don't have a problem.
I... I don't have a problem.
Anyway, today we're going to be playing Senuality Echo of Ada.
Thank you so much to Bandai for saving me from my crippling Marvel Rivals addiction.
I really appreciate it.
If they weren't there to save me from this problem that...
Not problem that I have, I might have streamed another day of Marvel Rivals.
So, thank you to Bandai for giving us variety in our lives.
This was my intervention.
I really appreciate it.
So, anyway, Marvel...
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Bandai.
Anyway, Bandai asked me to check out the PvP mode today.
So, remember when I was avoiding PvP this entire time?
The last sponsor?
So, this time, we're going to actually try out PvP.
So, we're going to actually kill some robots.
Sorry.
Eliminate some robots.
So, because last time I was trying to avoid confrontation because I was scared.
This time, I actually have to like...
I have to see if I can like...
Kill some other robots and see what...
I'm worried because the open network test came out a couple days ago when I was in Atlanta.
Or like the day before I was in Atlanta.
So, I feel like a lot of the players now might have a lot of gear.
Might be like super stocked up.
So, that's the one thing I'm really worried about.
I'm going to try and PvP and then I get my...
I don't know.
I'm just going to get my robot head kicked in.
Blazing gun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, I'm now addicted to Marvel because of you and my friends.
Going to play rank all day to see where I'll end up.
Wish me luck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry.
I'm a problem.
It's like...
Oh my god.
It's like those smoked like cigarette boxes.
And then they print like on the picture of like this is what happens if you smoke.
But you just still do it anyway.
Like...
I'm so sorry.
That's...
That's me right now.
You see like there is a problem but you still go for it anyway.
I'm so sorry.
I'm...
Anyway.
Anyway, I'm super excited to check out Senuality.
I love how Bandai replied to my tweet.
My sponsored tweet.
And was like...
Let's see if she'll like...
Let's see if she'll continue to upgrade the bathroom.
I wonder if it...
I wonder if it like...
Carries over the stuff I did in the bathroom.
I would be so...
Okay.
I will be sad if it doesn't carry over.
But like...
It's not the end of the world.
But I will be sad.
Those...
Those four hours...
The four hours for the bathroom just for it to go away.
I will be sad.
Oh no.
It didn't!
We're not...
I can't.
I can't do this again, guys.
I can't do the bathroom again.
Guys, please.
I can't.
I'll do this so people will know it's not me.
And then like...
People will know it's not me.
So they won't try and kill me.
Oh yeah, the intro!
I'm cool.
I'm pretty cool.
I legitimately forgot the entire intro.
So let's watch it again.
I just realized chat's dead.
We'll look at the chat later.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Oh yeah, and then we created waifus to cure our depression.
See, it works.
That's what I am.
Technically.
That's what VTubers are technically.
We're depressed.
Let's create AI waifus.
Why am I...
There's a deeper problem then.
That's me!
Again!
I haven't unpacked yet.
No, I have absolutely not unpacked.
That's me.
That's the coffin!
Because you die in the mech suit.
Guys, I'll unpack when I make it to GM.
I hope I make it today.
I'm supposed to pick up dad...
in...
three hours.
Wait, how do I join that side?
That side sounds fun.
Wait, why do I have to be a good guy?
How do I join the other side?
They have the black market.
They literally have the fucking supply for energy.
Okay, but...
Toki, do you not want equal access?
Okay, but like, do they deserve equal access?
That's all I'm saying.
Some people might not deserve it.
It's not like...
Like, do you really need electricity?
And we can...
And we can live in a...
It was like, you know, millions of years ago.
We can live in a world where, like, without energy...
Like, do we really...
Like, before electricity was invented...
Like, we were okay.
We were doing okay.
So, like, you know...
Maybe...
You can stop here.
Where's the three displays?
Oh, here.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot.
My waifu is so hot that she has too many polygons.
I keep forgetting about that.
LOL
I forgot she's so hot that she...
Her polygons take up so much.
LOL Oh my god, why are you so hot?
Why?
Okay, we'll fix this later.
We can't...
We can't change the settings until...
Until, like...
Until we're, like, out of this area.
Which is fine.
Why, virtual waifu?
Why?
Why are you...
Why do you have 8 million polygons?
LOL You know...
Actually, no, Dragoons.
You know why.
You know why she has 8 million polygons.
Yippee!
Oh, man.
So, what do you think?
Honestly.
So long as it's not raining...
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Rain hurts me.
It's time to get to work.
Use AO search to find crystals.
Oh, wait.
Isn't it this?
Yeah.
There we go.
Where?
Go to the location shown at the top right of your display.
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
I got...
Thank god they did this, because I legitimately forgot the controls.
Yeah, that's right.
Get down.
I had FPS training.
Oh, whoops.
LOL My anime waifu was like, There's too many.
Don't shoot.
I say as I...
As I shot before I heard her finish her sentence.
That's...
That's awkward.
LOL Don't shoot.
We gotta evade them.
I'm like, sorry, what did you say?
Sorry, I didn't hear you.
What did you want me to do before I killed...
Okay, recover.
How's the sound, by the way?
Whoa.
Whoa, the size doesn't count.
Whoa, it's how you use it.
Whoa.
That's messed up.
It's pure energy!
Okay.
It is good?
That's good.
Alright.
I'm excavating.
I did my job.
Are you proud of me?
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Okay, but where's the return elevator?
Use return points to summon an elevator and ride your way to safety.
Okay.
Oh, it's this way.
Alright, that's fine.
Are you lagging or just me?
It's sort of like...
She's so...
She's so hot that like...
She's so hot that I can't keep up right now.
I...
I just...
I can't keep up at the moment.
We gotta wait a little bit before it's fixed.
Alright.
Here we go.
Prisma, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Today is my birthday.
Float to the land of the sea, phantom thief!
As a birthday gift.
I'm happy to tell you that I've been playing...
Marvel Rivals most of the day.
Thanks to you.
Thank you for the super chat, Prisma.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Prisma.
Yay!
And I'm so sorry.
I'm...
This is you on Marvel Rivals.
Thank you, Bandai, for giving me an intervention.
I really appreciate it.
Come on, why is it still raining?
Okay.
Oh, what?
It's still raining?
When will it stop?
Weather, please.
Why is it still raining?
My wife!
Stop the rain!
Change the weather right now and stop the rain, my wife.
Oh, we're not going home.
Oh, am I just supposed to go?
Oh.
But it hurts.
The outside.
It hurts so much.
Please, it's hurting my body.
Please, can you talk a little faster?
My body, it hurts so much.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, look at her go.
Yeah, that's her.
Yeah, that's my wife right there.
She did that.
Please,
stop.
I'm trying!
Alright.
Oh, of course it stops raining now.
Yay!
Nothing bad is going to happen in those five seconds.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
There we go.
We did it!
Did I pass?
You think I did really good?
I did?
Oh, don't worry.
I can replace them.
Yay!
I did it!
Yoki, what do you mean by replace?
Don't worry, I'm going to replace her right now.
I'm going to...
Because I'm going to replace her right now.
Oh, yeah.
I remember this was beta.
Beta, alpha, beta...
Wait, which one?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, this...
Was this beta?
Beta, alpha, beta, alpha.
I remember.
Choose four!
They're beta, though!
Wait, wasn't one of them used to be omega?
Did they change the type?
I remember one of them was an omega.
Did they change one of the types?
Alright.
We're going to be an alpha wife.
I'm going to have an alpha wife.
Four.
Do you guys really, really want me to pick four?
Do you really want me to pick four?
Dang, they're all...
No!
Three!
No, ducky!
We want the alpha.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, we're going back to what we know.
What do we could do?
We could do one.
Okay.
I don't know.
They're all so cute.
I think I had three last time, right?
I'm pretty sure.
I'm really happy.
Alright, do we want someone new?
Do we want default lady?
Default lady?
Three?
Or him?
We could take all of his clothes...
We could technically take his clothes off.
Like, to make...
One for variety.
Alright, alright.
I'm going to give you guys a poll, guys.
One, two, or three.
Which anime...
Waifu should we get?
One, three.
I like how two is not even an option.
Two is nobody's option.
Matrix, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Skibity Toilet collab.
Drops on Fortnite tomorrow.
And I gotta remind everyone to use the creator code ToadKeeper tomorrow.
I can't believe Skibity Toilet is going to be part of Fortnite.
Because I'm like thinking, doesn't Valve own the models, technically?
Like, how did they get away...
How did the fucking person who created Skibity Toilet get away with all of it?
Because it's literally a fucking Valve model.
Like, it's like...
Stop saying those words.
I don't know how they got away with it, because it's also a Halloween costume.
Okay.
Guys, I like how four is a very vocal minority.
Like, the people in chat is like, four!
But it was like, just like a very tiny percentage of them.
And then all the lurkers are like, you are not making...
I am not...
I am here to lurk, and you are not giving me four.
It's not fair.
Like, if I look at chat, it looked like four was the most popular vote.
But they were just very vocal about what they love.
Our love for four is true.
Alright.
Okay, it's...
Oh, it's very close.
I'm gonna wait until the votes hit a thousand before...
Ultra model S can become 9S.
I'm just saying.
Isn't like...
Isn't that a guy?
Isn't 9S...
Wait, 9S...
Oh wait, 9S is also...
Okay, I was thinking about the other one.
Yeah, but like...
We don't care about 9...
Wait, I shouldn't say that.
Because I have never played...
I have never played Nier before.
And I'm worried that people are like, I care!
I care about 9S!
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna give you a countdown.
Five...
Oh, I think 3-1.
We're going back to the classic.
Okay, weather...
Weather gazer.
Cradle support.
What is...
I forgot what they do.
Okay, weather gazer specializes in weather.
Specializes in cradle maintenance.
Significant increases repair kit.
Which one's good for PvP?
Displays ender's health features that facilitates cradles and analytic.
Okay, 3 is the winner.
Guys, which one's great for PvP?
A system special...
Guys, if you read this...
If you really want 4...
Damn me.
You should download Sinuality right now.
And get 4.
Cradles health features that restrains any...
Oh, wait.
This is good.
Yeah, 3.
3 for PvP.
Yeah.
Guys, if you really want 4, you can also have 4 for your own...
For your own mecha fight.
Alright.
I'm trying to remember, like...
Oh, is this new?
Oh, my God.
I love Latina.
Okay.
I still like the default one.
I don't know.
I think default one has always...
Has been, like, the best so far.
Alright.
She's gotta be...
I gotta have...
Oh, okay.
Maybe not that.
Whoa.
Okay, maybe a little.
Short kings, rise up.
It's time.
Alright.
Let's see.
I like her normal hair color.
Not gonna lie.
Actually, I just...
I like her default hairstyle a lot more.
Oh, wait.
But...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay.
Some of these hair...
These are...
I don't think this was a feature.
Okay.
Maybe not that.
Oh, my God.
She's a little...
She's a...
She's, like...
A little special.
Because, like...
She dyed one streak of her hair...
Red.
Oh, my God.
But then she could...
She could be the mom that dies in every anime, though.
Yeah, these are new.
These are new.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Wait.
These are all so cute.
I don't...
Maybe I should get the mom hairstyle.
She could be the...
The mom that dies in the beginning of the episode.
The mom hair.
It's the mom hair!
It's, like...
It's, like, basically, like...
You know?
People with, like...
Mommy issues.
Because they're, like...
My mom died in that one anime episode.
So, they recreated her into, like...
A...
Oh, no.
That's really bad.
Never mind.
Because I remember there were, like...
Supposed to be, like...
So, like, that's really bad.
That's really bad.
And my mom will always be there.
But it's so cute.
It is.
It's so cute, though.
Alright.
Honestly, I like how it looks so far.
She's really cute.
Okay.
I think...
I think I like this.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
The back...
No, you're right.
Guys.
Oh, my god.
But it's such a cute hairstyle.
But then I realized...
The bathtub scene is not...
Is not it.
Like...
Oh, my god.
No.
You're right.
You're so right.
Okay, guys.
We're gonna...
We're gonna change the hairstyle.
I...
I can't be responsible for that.
We're gonna...
Oh, my god.
They're all so cute.
They're all such cute hairstyles.
I don't know.
I'm so bad.
Oh, wait.
That's...
That's sort of me.
That's like retro me.
Wait.
I could...
Okay.
It's me.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna put myself in here, too.
It's me.
Okay.
We're gonna do that.
Oh, but I still wanna be...
I wanna be tall.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay.
We gotta...
We gotta be more accurate here with the...
We gotta be a little accurate here.
You know?
You know, guys?
We just...
We're just trying to be for accuracy.
You know?
Just...
Just trying...
Alright.
I think that's good.
Okay.
Yeah!
What's the makeup?
We're just gonna spend our entire time right here, I feel like.
It doesn't feel like it changes.
Okay.
We'll do two.
And then...
Eyeshadow.
I don't know.
I think default is fine.
Honestly.
Oh, blush!
Hi!
Alright.
Mouth shape.
I think normal is fine.
Alright, there we go.
That's fine.
Woah!
Nice.
Alright.
Which one's the real Doki?
This one's the real Doki.
Not Doki and real Doki.
Alright.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh my god, that's me!
I made myself.
See?
I made her.
Oh wait!
Fuck the eye color!
Oh my god!
I'll change her later.
I...
The one thing I forgot is the eye color.
I was paying attention with like so many other things and I forgot what my eye color was.
You don't look at your own eyes!
That's what I'm saying!
Okay, can you really blame me?
I don't look at my eyes, okay?
I look at other stuff.
Yeah, you can.
I'm pretty sure you can edit.
Alright.
I'm gonna change your eyes.
Okay.
Real Doki.
Fake.
Yeah, what's wrong with it?
This is my bachelor pad.
You like it?
That is giving me BAPTA PTSD.
Alright, before we do all that, I'm gonna change you.
Oh, is that the remake ticket?
Is that it?
Oh shit.
Oh yeah, guys!
Pre-order!
It's gonna be on sale on January 24th!
And y'all, access at Jan...
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, game, for helping me with my sponsor.
On January 17th.
So you can pre-order it now!
Woo!
There's gonna be some pre-order bonuses as well.
So make sure you check...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, I can't...
Wait, can I?
Okay, it's time.
Oh wait.
How do I...
Alright.
It's fine.
I used my one ticket just to change your eye color.
It's worth it.
I just...
My one ticket is just for the eyes.
Guys, you don't understand.
It's worth it, guys.
It's so worth it.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Eye color, both.
Okay.
I want both of them to be...
It doesn't even change that much!
Are you serious?!
My one edit doesn't even change that much!
I'm so sad.
I'm so...
Okay.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
I'm trying to figure out what color makes it pop, makes the green pop up more.
Okay, maybe it's this one.
Maybe?
Is there other green?
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god.
This was yellow this entire time.
I couldn't tell.
Guys, I swear I'm not coloring.
I didn't realize.
Okay, there we go.
This color or...
Oh, I like this green more.
This green or this green, guys?
Which one?
This green or this green?
Or the lighter green?
Alright.
You know what?
We'll go with this one.
Alright.
I think I like this one.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we can...
145.
Oh my god.
Do not be afraid.
It just kicked in.
I got the catnip.
You know, I thought when it says eye size, I thought it would be like...
I thought it would be like this eye size.
Alright, there we go.
My one edit.
Yes.
Alright, here we go.
Yes, I literally used my one edit for that.
That's fine.
Okay, now we gotta wear new clothes.
Okay.
Oh, I don't like the jacket.
I'm gonna take the jacket out.
Where's the jacket?
I love the innerwear more, I think.
I think the innerwear looks so cute.
Versus like...
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Wait, was it this?
It's this, right?
Okay, no outerwear bottoms.
There we go.
I just think like this is so cute.
In general.
What are you guys looking at?
My eyes are up here.
My eyes are...
What are you looking at?
Alright.
Let's see.
Or we can have a jacket with it.
No, I think I personally...
I personally think...
I think this is really cute.
Okay, shoes.
And then we'll do yellow shoes.
And then...
Wait, I can have wings?
Oh my god, this game has everything.
I can have wings.
What was it?
This was the original, right?
Uhh...
Yeah, I like this outfit more.
Alright, there we go.
You're beautiful now.
Alright.
Prep, pre-order now.
Oh, we have requests.
Welcome to the life of a brand new drifter.
We're in complete missions.
Alright, we don't need to know all this because we're here to kill.
Bounty hunter ranking.
Alright, and who's gonna be killing me?
Wait, is there no bounty hunters?
Oh, it's connecting.
I wanna see the other drifters.
I wanna see what they look like.
I wanna know who's gonna...
Who's gonna be hunting me down.
We're here for...
We're here for murder.
Yay!
I'm still connecting to the rankings though.
Connecting?
It says connecting.
Oh, there it is.
This is the ranking of drifters affiliated with the association that compete.
You can collect a large sum by defeating the higher ranked bounty targets.
Alright.
I like how you can...
Oh my god, wait, is that...
Don Don and Don Don Don girl?
Wait, I think that is.
Wait, she looks like the...
I like to see like...
What they look like.
Cause you can tell like what their type is by like how they dress their magus.
So I thought...
Wait, what?
Wait!
No!
There was a person with...
I like how the person with four doesn't exist anymore.
There used to be like several people with four.
With the beta guy.
In the...
In the closed network test.
Yeah, we're just...
Oh, this guy.
This guy likes moms.
I like how everybody has a sweater though.
This guy.
Are we gonna see our first...
When are we gonna see the first one with a male magus?
Are we...
Are we gonna find any of them?
They're all waifus.
There's zero...
There's zero men.
They're all waifus.
Guys.
This ain't looking good for the beta lovers.
It ain't looking good for you guys.
I don't think I've seen...
I don't think...
I've seen a single beta here.
It's just...
It's all threes.
Threes and ones.
You know what that means.
Oh my god, excuse me?
Like...
Okay, that guy...
That guy has other things in his mind.
Like, oh my god.
It's cold!
She's cold!
Get her a jacket!
She's so cold!
Oh hey, there's two!
This guy likes...
Am I allowed to say it?
I was gonna say, this guy is a certain...
Okay, I...
I can't say that.
Probably...
Alright.
Alright, I caught myself before I could, guys.
I caught myself before...
Before I could.
I...
I stopped myself.
Alright.
Oh, they made one of the Arknight girls?
I'm not at brand risk.
Oh wait, isn't that, like, from...
Wait, actually, 51st...
I'm at 51st yet, now.
Guys...
Guys, you can't even...
Guys, it ain't looking so good for foreign joyers, guys.
You are a very, very vocal minority.
Oh wait, that's...
Hey!
That's Evangelion.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
I don't think I've seen a single one.
Oh my god.
We're at 51 right now.
We're...
We're at 51.
Where are they?
Not even one person has number 4?
Not even one?
There's no way.
I can't believe not a single one in the top 100 has...
Is using...
Is using number 4.
We're at 70.
We're at 70 now.
This ain't looking so good.
So this is the meta.
Portal for beta not found.
Huge loss for the bro.
Bro, I just wanted a homie.
Oh my god.
Thank you for...
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
We're at 81.
20 left.
Guys, maybe...
Guys, maybe we'll get...
Maybe it's at the last 20.
Guys, you don't know that.
Maybe...
Oh, 88.
What?
Oh.
Okay.
Is that a 2 or a 4?
Whoa.
That's just...
Oh, last 10.
Last 10.
Alright.
There's one left.
One more left.
Guys.
Are you willing to bet your life savings that I could be number 100?
Are you...
No way.
Trust.
It's over.
Alright.
But she's cute though.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
In the top 100, number 4 doesn't exist.
Wait, look.
They literally went through all 1 to 100.
They don't...
It doesn't exist.
It doesn't even fucking exist.
That's so funny.
He's so cute.
I really like his design.
Rest in peace, buff dudes.
No barra for you.
Sad day for the bros.
I need a bro shoulder to cry on, bro.
I love the animation.
It's so cute.
Bro.
Cas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For the gamers who's not here for the horny.
They just want a bro...
They just want a bro-lationship.
That's me.
Bro.
We just want a bro.
This is a bro-tastrophe.
Bro.
Wait, apparently there's like bounty tar...
Oh yes, cle...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
She's...
She's washing my dish...
She's washing my clothes.
I'm sorry.
Wait, is there like...
There's like other rankings too?
Guys, sorry.
We're gonna be back in the loading screen.
Guys, I wanna know like the...
The bou...
Maybe they're all bounty tar...
Maybe they're just PvPers, chat.
That's it.
The...
The bounty hunters are...
Are the...
Are everybody else.
And then the PvPers are the bros.
You know?
Bro, I just wanted to see my bro wash up.
That's...
Maybe that's it.
Oh my god.
Maybe you're here.
Oh, I like how this guy's just default.
He's like, I'm not here for the anime waifus.
I'm here to be a gamer.
I...
Maybe that's it.
Maybe you're just...
Oh, I knew it!
Oh my god!
There he is!
GeForce GT!
What?!
There he is, guys!
I knew it!
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted.
He's real!
He's there to...
He's there to kill.
Oh my god, and he has a 1030!
Oh my god!
He has a...
T...
T1030, guys!
A Nvidia T1030.
I fucking knew he exists.
I knew it.
I knew he was...
He was a fucking fighter.
God, I wanted a chair.
I knew it.
And...
And the fact that...
That he...
He's not here to play by the rules, chat.
He's here...
He's here to fucking...
He's here to fuck!
And he's top 5!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Our pro here.
Alright.
Let us...
It's PvP time.
I knew they existed.
I...
I knew it.
Okay, Northern Stone.
If you lose items, you can select which item you want.
Do I have...
Everything I want?
Automate or replenish?
Okay.
They're replenished already.
Alright.
I forgot to change my settings, but that's okay.
We'll do it right here.
Oh, that's right.
Get in the robot.
4 is saved.
I knew there was representatives for 4.
That's me.
That's real Doki.
That's real Doki and not Doki.
Oh, we don't need insurance.
It's the first level!
How bad can it get?
We don't need insurance here.
Alright.
Okay, let's...
I forgot to...
Guys, I forgot to...
Oh, wait.
Motion blur.
Guys, I forgot to fix my settings.
Alright.
We gotta find...
Is there anything here?
Why is there a little cubby hole here?
There's nothing here.
Yeah, this has...
It's PvPvE.
Oh my god, guys.
Give me a second.
Maybe if I close some tabs.
It all fails.
It's time to close some tabs.
Maybe I should close...
I don't remember.
Is there...
There's no graphic settings yet, right?
Because I remember that like...
There's like no graphic settings for...
For the network test.
Right?
Or is there...
I don't remember.
Do you guys remember?
Remember if there's like graphic settings?
I closed three tabs.
There were...
Oh, it's in the home base.
Okay, guys.
We're gonna...
We're gonna have to go power through this.
He's so...
He's dead.
Alright, nice.
Let's excavate real fast.
What is that?
No, that's a...
That's just a bad guy.
Dragoons.
Sign up for the open network test right now.
So I can...
So I can PvP you.
Come on.
PvP me.
Get in here, Dragoons.
Come on.
Don't you wanna PvP?
Oh, my God.
Look how...
Look how vulnerable I am with the over...
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Nice.
With the overclock.
Oh, my God.
I'm overheating.
Oh, I can't run.
Oh, no.
What would I do?
I can't run.
Oh, no.
Alright.
Don't you wanna fight me?
Whoa.
It's gonna be so easy to kill me, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wouldn't it be so easy right now?
Where's my melee?
Where is my melee?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need to figure out what my melee is.
Show tutorials on screen controller settings.
Okay.
Keyboard.
Wait.
What's that?
What the fuck?
Why is he green?
Wait.
He's green.
Why is he green?
Wait.
I don't remember this.
Other than being green?
Okay.
Move back.
Move right.
Stop.
Jump.
Action.
Switch.
Twitch to attack.
Melee is E.
Okay.
I don't...
Custom.
Okay.
There we go.
That should be...
Actually, no.
This should be back.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Oh, no.
It's raining.
Give me a sec.
Oh, no.
It's...
Oh, it's raining.
I didn't realize.
Oh, it's not raining.
I was just...
I'm just crazy.
Okay.
I need to make my melee.
Switch weapon.
Melee.
Apply.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
We got...
We got melee now.
Good.
Hello.
Is there anything here?
Oh, wait.
There's more supplies.
I don't remember what my mission is.
I've just been so preoccupied with PvP that I legitimately don't remember what my mission was.
Okay, nice.
Oh, they are?
Oh, yeah, you are.
Hey.
Hello?
Where are they?
Oh, I know you were excavating.
I know you were around.
Wait, where is he?
There he is.
Look at him.
There he is just casually rolling around.
There he is.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Wait, he's shooting me?
He's shooting me?
What the fuck?
I didn't think...
I thought I was in...
I didn't...
What?
He's shooting me?
This is not over.
This is not fucking over.
I am...
I refuse this to be over.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Leave.
I can't PvP.
You wanted PvP.
I didn't think...
What's my skill?
I don't know what I did.
Oh, I basically restrained them.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Guys, this is so bad.
Like, I'm...
This is so bad.
I wasted that.
I didn't know what it was.
Oh, no.
This is so bad.
Do I have heals at all?
Do I have...
We'll just use it for now.
That's right.
Get in here.
Get...
This is so bad.
Where's my heal?
I don't remember how to heal, guys.
Guys, get into this little circle.
That's right.
Get out.
I'm gonna shoot you.
That's right.
Get closer and you get shot.
I'm not friendly.
That's right.
Show yourself.
I'm not friendly.
That's right.
Jump.
I'll shoot you.
Oh, shit.
No, I'm sorry.
Guys, let me heal.
Let me heal.
I'm taking forever to heal.
Okay, wait.
Pause.
Let me heal first.
I'm trying to figure out how to heal.
Guys, how do I heal?
Okay.
Pause.
Pause the fight.
Guys, pause.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Pause.
Don't get closer.
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare get closer.
Don't you fucking dare.
Woah.
Oh, my god.
You fucker.
This is it.
I said pause.
I said...
Guys.
There's time outs in every fight.
There's time outs.
Guys, what happened to the integrity of pauses?
What happened?
Oh, no.
I never left.
We did it.
We successfully escaped.
You can't pause.
Yes, I can.
Pause.
Oh, my god.
What the fuck is an ender swarm?
Yeah.
I was a loot delivery service.
Where's the part where I try to PvP?
Guys, it's not my fault.
They didn't respect the time outs.
It's like sports where each team gets one time out per session.
Where the fuck was my time out?
This is where I saw PvP.
Stupid fucking Jake.
Fuck you, Jake.
Yeah, fucking run, Jake.
That's right.
Wait, and then he came back?
Oh, Jake keeps coming back.
That's right.
Oh, Jake.
Get away.
Get away, Jake.
That's...
Oh, wait.
Actually, it's all...
No, I won!
Jake!
It's not fair!
He healed!
This fucker healed.
God damn it.
Jake from State Far.
It wasn't fair!
No!
My last item!
Why didn't you guys tell me to get insurance?
Guys!
Why didn't you tell me to get insurance?
We could've avoided all this if I had insurance.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I think so as well.
Alright.
Prioritize performance.
Yes.
The game will return.
Okay.
We gotta prioritize performance right now.
I'm sorry.
You're gonna have to look a little less pretty.
My anime...
Real Doki.
Okay, this should work now.
This should be better.
Alright.
Start game.
Okay.
I figured it out.
I figured it out now.
Yes.
I figured it out.
It was just a fluke.
We don't need insurance.
Good morning.
Real Doki.
Alright, let's see.
I think that's...
Anti -alias.
Changing display mode.
Prioritize performance.
Alright.
That should be...
I know how to heal now.
Exactly.
Guys.
I know how to heal.
So everything will be okay now.
Things will be fine.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What can we do to fix the settings a little bit?
Do we have to change anti-aliasing?
As well as choose different modes?
It's alright.
We'll be fine.
Things will be fine.
Things will be so healthy now.
Alright.
Let's see.
Woah.
All she does is wash my clothes.
That's her only purpose, I guess.
Oh, wait.
Nice!
See guys?
Things are fine.
It gave me free stuff.
Okay.
We have...
What is this?
We don't need this.
This is...
Okay.
It's fine.
We're going back in.
Alright.
This is it.
She's already better than...
Real Doki is already better than not Doki.
Because she actually cleans.
She actually washes dishes.
Oh my god.
She's already such an improvement.
Alright.
This is fine.
We'll be fine.
Okay.
This one.
And then this one.
This is a shotgun.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, Jake.
I'm fucking ready, Jake.
Get over here.
That's right.
Challenge me!
Will anyone...
Is anyone here to challenge me?
Come on.
Where's my rematch, Jake?
Get your ass over here.
Fucking leave your world and come back here.
I'm ready, Jake.
Okay.
We gotta kill this guy.
That's right.
What is he gonna do?
Kill me?
Come on.
Where are all the drifters?
Where are you at?
Come on.
I'm right here.
That's right.
Get back here, Jake.
I want my fucking revenge.
1v1 me, Jake.
Jake, dunk on her.
No, this time it'll be different.
It'll be so different.
You see, if he hunts me down too much, he's gonna become a bounty target.
What's my ammo situation right now?
Okay, it's fine.
174 is fine.
There you go.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
See?
So easy.
Come on.
Where are all the cradles at?
Where'd you at?
Oh, woah, average?
Woah.
Well, don't say that.
Woah!
No!
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Wow.
Thank you, RealDoki.
I wouldn't have known that they explode.
No.
Okay.
I need you to repair me.
Alright, here we go.
Thank you, RealDoki.
I really appreciate the repairs.
Alright.
Okay, now!
Now, Jake!
Now you can show up.
Alright, Jake.
I figured it out.
Alright, let's get excavating.
Oh, they are?
Oh, this takes us so long to excavate.
Hey, you wouldn't shoot me while I'm excavating, right?
That'd be a little fucked up.
Are you trying to kill me while I'm trying to excavate?
That's so fucked up.
Chaser, stay there.
Stay there, Chaser.
Stay there!
Okay, nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay, there's Chaser right there.
Alright, he's feeling it right now so we can ignore him.
Okay, there was a cradle.
Is he still trying to figure out how to find a door?
Okay.
I know there's a guy here.
There was a guy here.
Come on!
Where you at?
Oh, I know what to do.
I'm gonna say hi to them.
And then, like, wait for them to come close to me.
And they'll think I'm a good person.
Where did he go?
He's over there.
That has to be him.
Is he up there?
Hello?
Oh no, not the rain.
Not the rain.
Oh, where's the cover?
Where's the cover?
No!
Not the acid rain!
There's no cover anywhere!
He's over there, though.
He's over there.
Oh no, I can't.
I can't find any cover.
I can't.
Oh, hey!
Hey.
Yeah?
Say hi back!
Nice!
Understood.
Well, let's step in the rain.
Yeah, let's go!
We gotta find cover together, friend!
Let's find cover together!
Come on!
Yeah?
We're such good friends!
Right?
What exactly is your game plan?
Download my Association Member and it won't go unnoticed.
Association Member Bailout Confirmed.
You want to live?
Download immediately.
Yoink.
No.
I need to get rid of stuff.
Give me a sec.
How do I get rid of it?
How do I-
It was worth it.
I think I would catch you.
It was so worth it.
He trusted you!
That's fine.
Let's get this fully up.
He trusted you and it's so fucked!
PvP successful.
Let's go home.
We did our job.
She must be punished.
What did I do?
You were there for the whole plan!
You were part of the problem.
You were also there for the plan.
I told you guys my plan very early on.
No, no, no, no!
No!
What did I do?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just wanted to use the- Oh my god, I just wanted to-
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, no.
No.
I can't believe Karma exists.
I can't believe Karma existed.
There's no way.
Wait, can they hit me in the elevator?
No!
You're such a bitch!
My elevator!
Can I open it again?
Can I open you again?
No!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
It's not Karma, I'm still alive.
I'm still alive, it's not Karma, guys.
It's not Karma.
Karma!
Don't worry, Karma won't get me.
Don't worry, I'm friend.
I'm friend, see?
Hello, I'm friendly.
Hello, I'm so friendly, guys.
I'm so friendly.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm so friendly.
Guys, I'm so friendly.
Look, look guys.
Yay!
I'm a good person.
I'm so friendly, everybody.
I would never hurt anyone.
Who did I even kill?
We're all friendly here.
I didn't...
She got away with murder.
What's wrong with society?
What's wrong with this world?
Can't believe she got away.
Alright.
When did I kill him?
Where was he?
Alright.
And then...
Oh, and then I'm like, hi!
Hi!
Oh wait, no.
Wait, where was the part where I killed somebody?
Okay.
Okay, times two.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh wait.
No, that's not him.
Where is he?
Oh, is it cement liquor?
Is that him?
Wait.
I think it is.
Oh wait, no.
It has to be...
Oh no.
Wait, you don't even see him.
SilverEye at 512.
The fuck?
Where does 512 come from?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he's just there to look at the weather!
Wait, that's so sad!
He was literally there.
He was literally there to look at the weather.
He's not even...
He's actually...
He was just...
He was just a weatherman.
He's literally...
His skill was just to be a weatherman.
I killed...
I killed the...
I killed the weatherman!
Terrible day for a raid.
This fucker.
This guy.
Bro, fuck this guy.
Who even are you?
Alright, that's fine.
I got my PvP.
Guys, I did it.
I did a PvP.
Poor weather girl.
Where's my crystal haul?
Let's cash out our haul.
What did I get?
Oh my god!
Shoutout to that guy who farmed it for me.
It's a new payout record.
Moving on, here's a rundown of the items you've obtained.
Looks like you got some...
Oh shit, wait.
What happened to my eyes?
Whoops.
Nice.
And now, let's take a look at the request progress you've made.
Bring it back.
Oh hey, nice.
I did it.
Yeah.
How did I do, Association?
Did I do okay?
Oh.
Whoops.
No, don't shun me!
No!
I mean, like, we just had two weather people.
They couldn't shun me.
Now, I'm gonna be put on the no-fly list, chat.
I killed one person, and now that makes me a bad guy?
What happened to forgiveness?
Huh?
What happened?
As long as I confess to my sins, all should be forgiven.
Is that not what Jesus would have wanted?
Is that?
Yes, it does.
If I go to confessional right now and be like, I'm sorry, Father, for I have sinned.
I accidentally killed a weatherman.
But I definitely did not mean to.
And then everything would be fine, as long as I repented.
So I shouldn't be shunned after that.
Alright, I learned a lot today.
I learned how to...
I know if I just be like, hello!
Hello!
I did it!
Also, how's the sound for her?
Do you hear her?
Oh, I'm marketable.
Oh, very low?
You guys should have said something!
There you go.
I put it higher.
Alright.
Oh, I can... Okay, I should get another request.
Alright, we got another one.
Oh, we got... We finished this.
Some real Jeff from Marvel rivals became here to shake my head.
Lord, grossest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got another one!
I'm an adult.
Here's the thing to learn about requests.
Just complete them.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Plushie guy.
Yay!
The more quests you complete, the more you'll have available to you.
The more weathermen I can kill.
Alright, let's see.
Upgrade your craft station.
Okay, we gotta get... Upgrade craft station and defeat the Mount of Enders.
Okay, and then...
Oh my god.
This place is a fucking dump.
But the rent's cheap at least, you know?
Repair your garage.
Try repairing the walls and ceilings.
Alright, I should be able to.
Upgrade my wall.
Alright, at least the walls will look a little better, right?
Yay!
We're not doing the bathroom.
Guys, I cannot commit to another bathroom chat.
I cannot.
It was 4 plus hours of grinding, guys.
I cannot do this all again.
I got scammed by my wife.
By myself.
She only gave me 2 seconds.
Oh, real Doki, what did you do?
Does it sound better, guys?
What did you improve?
There's glass on the floor.
Doki!
What do you mean?
There's glass on the floor!
You upgraded the floor?
What do you mean?
You fixed this.
There's glass on the floor, Doki!
That is not fixing.
It's okay.
She's trying her best, guys.
I'm trying my best right now.
I'll up the volume a little bit more.
She said she fucking fixed it!
Why is there glass on the floor?
We're living as good as heart.
We're living in hard times, Doki.
Alright, walls and ceiling.
Alright.
Oh, it's not heisting.
We're literally here to murder.
She's perfect.
She's perfect for you, Doki.
What do you mean?
Alright, she's picking up the weeds.
She said she would fix the floor!
I don't think you're allowed to eat weeds.
What did I get?
These nutrient-rich weeds will be a perfect main dish tonight.
My main dish?
I need protein!
Wait, this is like... I'm looping.
I remember this.
I'm actually looping.
She did this before.
Please, wife.
Please, Doki.
I need protein.
This cannot be the main dish.
I can't eat.
Just eat grass.
Oh, yay!
Craft station!
Did I do it?
Did I do it, Doki?
You can do all this, but you can't clean fucking glass.
Like, what's wrong with you?
Yay!
The pit space?
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Now we can fucking craft now.
Alright, station one.
Do I need to craft anything?
I feel like...
Oh, yeah.
Excavator part.
Materials.
Whoa!
That's a lot of stuff.
Oh, and I got consumables, too.
Okay, pit space.
Can I upgrade it?
No, I need degraded plastic piece.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright, give me my money.
I did my job.
I made my... I made real Doki to do my job for me.
I contracted it out.
Alright, nice.
And then... Is it time?
Okay, we need degraded plaster pieces.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta put some stuff away.
Okay.
Alright, so...
We don't need this.
Okay.
Move to...
How do I move this?
Oh, repair equipment.
Ten thousand...
Wait, it's... Oh, ten... Okay, it's not that much.
Alright.
Repaired everything.
And then...
Move, move.
Move this.
We'll keep all of this for now.
Oh, okay.
Music and sound effects down.
Okay, that's cool.
I'll do that.
Okay, and then... Automated.
Okay, items.
Alright, there we go.
That should be good.
Alright, and then we'll fix the audio a little bit.
We'll put that at 60.
And then we'll put that at 60.
And then we'll raise...
Alright, that should be good.
Alright.
Can I buy...
Faster legs?
Oh, I can't.
Not yet.
I want to buy faster legs.
My legs are too...
My legs are so...
They're so...
They're so short.
I need faster legs.
No, I don't have the recipes yet.
Oh, it's alright.
Maybe I can kill somebody for faster legs.
Alright.
We don't need insurance.
I have a starter kit on.
Alright, it's time.
Alright.
Here we go.
Maybe some guy would have faster legs.
I'm gonna kill somebody for better legs.
I'm gonna amputate their legs and then sew it onto mine.
Yoki, that is the wild thing you said today.
It's time.
Time!
As long as I confess to my sins, I will be forgiven.
I'll be forgiven as long as I confess.
Oh my, you're right.
You know what they say about four legs.
Jake, where are you, Jake?
Where the fuck are you, Jake?
I'm waiting for you.
I know you're here.
I'm gonna find you, Jake.
I'm gonna fucking find you.
Nice.
Come on, Jake.
I know you're here.
I know you're still around.
You've been playing this game.
You can't fucking get away from me, Jake.
Okay, we're- Oh my god!
Are you at the exit?
Okay, we gotta slowly head to the exit.
Alright, we gotta just- There has to be people just like walking around the exit, so I'm just gonna slowly walk over there.
You can find him and stay- Bro, the exit's like a thousand five hundred meters away!
Oh, there's too much grass here.
Too much- Oh my god, it's too beautiful.
The grass polygons is insane.
I don't need to worry about the chaser.
Oh wait, I do need to care about it.
Oh no.
Oh no, where's cover?
Where's cover?
How do I get cover?
Oh my god, there's- There's a bridge right here!
Come on!
Get your legs working!
Okay, I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay now.
Oh shit, what the fuck were you doing here?
Nice.
I'm glad that he came to me.
Is it still raining?
Hello?
Is it still rain- Oh, it is.
God damn it!
Control the weather!
Where's my- Ever since I killed the weather boy, it's never stopped raining.
Is this karma?
Ever since.
It never stopped raining.
Weather boy, please come back.
Weather boy.
Please come back.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I killed you.
It was just- You were just there.
You were there.
It was just so easy.
You were like, Hi, I'm Paul.
And I was like, Hi, I'm also Paul.
I couldn't help it.
He was just there.
So vulnerable.
I'll be like, She's not sorry.
I am.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to.
Is it still raining?
Oh my god!
Okay, it stops.
Okay, it's stopping.
It's stopping.
I'll take care of his family and his wife.
Don't worry.
Do not worry about his wife.
I'll be there for her.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait, we need to- Yeah, we need to hunt this guy.
Come down!
Get down!
Oh, wait, but there's- There's excavating here.
Nice.
Regulus, you should sign up right now to the open network test.
And then you too.
You too can be part of it.
And then I'll be like, Hi!
Hi, I'm friendly!
Guys, if you come over here, if you sign up right now, right into my server right now, you'll be the one who I don't shoot because you're gonna be the special one.
Guys, don't worry.
You'll be the special one who I don't kill.
It could be you.
Don't trust her.
No, we can work together, Dragoon.
We can work together and kill the non-Dragoons together.
Guys, it's a trap.
Believe me, I would never do such a thing.
I'm not a terrible person.
See, I'm just shooting...
See, guys?
I'm just shooting PvE.
Guys, I would never...
In my mind, it's just PvE.
It was just a one-time thing.
Pay used to be believable.
How is this not believable?
I don't understand.
I'm just a little bird trying to make it in this world.
Oh, you know what that means.
A faint sound of an engine.
A faint sound of an engine, guys.
Oh, he's right there.
He's right there.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, he's right there.
What's his name?
Wait, there's more than one.
There's another one right there.
Alright, is he a good person?
Oh, there he is!
Hi!
Hey!
Are we good friends?
Can we be friends?
Hey!
Friend?
What about you?
You wanna be friends too?
Oh my god, he's gonna be friends!
Wait.
Look, friend.
Friend?
Let's go, let's work together.
Look, we're friends.
All three of us.
Hey guys!
Oh my god.
WHAT THE- OH MY GOD, WHAT?!
THAT'S SO FUN!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I was- Oh my god!
I had self-protection!
Oh, this is a fight club!
What the fuck?!
I actually got into a fight club!
Holy shit!
I actually got into a fucking fight club!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god, that was an accident.
I didn't realize this was a fight club.
I just wouldn't- I was just trying to bait.
I was like, welcome to fight club.
Overloaded?
I don't need this.
Okay.
Oh shit, degraded burst rifle.
Oh my god, what's this?
Wait, what is this?
Is this a good gun?
Oh my god, wait.
Really?
For me?
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to put some stuff away.
Oh, I stole their wo- I stole- I stole his woman!
That's right, it's mine now!
I stole it!
Oh, it's the gun I killed him- Oh, I basically- That was a good gun too?
Oh shit!
Wait!
I want the gun back!
Wait a minute!
That was a good gun!
Are we friends?
Can we be friends?
Friends?
Yeah?
Friend?
Give me back my gun.
I want that gun.
I also want that gun too.
That looked like a good gun.
That looked really good.
I'm dropping this.
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait, how do I- Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh, we got a sniper!
You can't keep getting away with this!
There we go.
Goodbye.
Now I leave.
Crime is fun.
Wait, does he have good legs?
What was his legs like?
Guys!
Was it good legs?
Or bad legs?
I need to steal good legs.
Good legs only.
They're not default ones?
Oh, that's what I like to hear.
Oh my god, they are good legs!
Oh my god, okay.
What do I get rid of though?
Oh my god, wait.
How do I take my legs off and take his legs?
How do I take his legs?
I want your legs!
Okay, I'm gonna drop this.
And I'll drop this and this.
So I can take your legs.
I need your legs.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, there we go.
My legs now.
I don't have inventory space, guys.
I can't.
My legs now.
I need to figure out how to get back up here.
I need to figure out how to get back up there.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta figure out how to get back up top.
It's fine.
We don't need the guns.
We got what we came for.
Wait, what?
There's an invisible wall here.
Oh no.
I'm just stupid.
We gotta get out of here.
Guys, we gotta get out.
Okay.
It was a 50 that's fine.
We don't need the sniper, guys.
Guys, we don't need it.
We're fine.
Guys, I can't.
Guys, we gotta figure out how to get out of here.
Oh no.
They're gonna take my legs too.
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm scared they're gonna take my legs.
I need to get out of here.
I can't have them take my legs.
I can't.
I worked so hard for these legs.
Oh no.
The po-po's coming.
I need to keep my legs.
I need to keep it.
Oh my god.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh, thank god.
What?
Oh, okay.
They're just excavating.
Oh, oh.
They're coming.
The cops are coming for the legs.
Say no!
They- Oh, I lived!
I lived!
There's the leg thief.
I got my legs!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Never punished.
I escaped.
I kidnapped I kidnapped their animate wife and I got their legs.
Let's fucking go.
I'm putting her up for ransom.
You want your animate wife back?
She's right here.
That's crazy.
Clean getaway.
Who did I kill?
Who the fuck did I kill?
A battle ensued, but we successfully escaped.
Alright.
Precipitation decreased here.
The rain clouds cleared up here.
This is where I was stuck here for the longest time.
Encountered a chaser at this location.
Okay, the first one was a legit fight.
I killed a real- They shot first!
They shot first, but they were so fucking stupid because I had a shotgun.
Encountered an ender swarm at this location.
I don't even know who I killed.
I know whose wife I stole.
Oh, there they are.
Oh my god, there they are.
They all- Oh, there they are.
A battle ensued, but we successfully escaped.
We escaped?
Oh, there it is.
That's Jake!
Oh my god!
It's Jake!
Vindication!
I killed Jake from stage 4!
We fucking did it!
Fuck you, Jake!
Fuck you!
Get shit on!
I killed Jake and took his fucking legs!
Oh my god!
It's a trophy now.
And there's me and- Here's where we obtained crafting materials.
There's me and the other guy.
Jake and his wife.
I took his wife too!
I took- Oh my god, he ran away.
Oh my god, this other person- I love- I almost- I almost like- Bro, that shit's crazy.
I'm leaving.
He's just like- And then poor poor Samsaru.
Poor Samsaru.
He was like- He was like, friend?
You're such a menace.
And I stole his legs.
So cruel.
It's the strat.
You don't understand.
That's the strat.
That's how you win.
Give them a false sense of security and then shoot them in the back of the head.
That's so fucked.
Oh my god.
Yay!
Our haul, guys.
My haul.
I rescued her!
I- I saved her.
That's- Guys, I saved her.
Oh my god.
I found this poor Magus out here all alone.
Without a player.
Oh my god.
Guys, look at these things!
There you are!
Alright.
We did it!
Nice legs.
I saved the wife and beautiful legs from Jake.
I'm such a wonderful person.
See?
Guys, remember to pre-order it now if you're seeing me have lots of fun.
And also, if you have fun in the open network test, pre-order it now.
Alright, how do I...
How do I wear my new legs?
Guys.
This?
I wanna wear it.
How do I wear you?
What happened?
Wait.
Did I put everything away?
What happened to my legs?
Why put everything away?
Put in your leg slot?
Oh, there it is!
Nice.
And then...
Alright, nice.
That should be it.
I could put the...
Alright, nice.
Look at that.
I have...
I wanna be able to carry more weight for the...
Cause I feel like I'm always running out of...
I'm always overloaded.
Alright, let's see if I can...
Parts...
No consumables.
Oh, do I need like a new body?
Oh, I completed a request there.
Yeah, but I don't wanna...
Oh, I got new stock!
Okay, I can craft spider arms.
Oh, that's a lot of stuff.
Buy any of the following amount of submachine gun.
Defeat the following amount of enders.
Use the following amount of Magus skills.
Okay, we don't need that.
Item shop.
Oh, these are...
Okay, now I have new arms.
Can only use energy, but optimize their profits.
Allows for height and power against... Wait!
I should get that!
Mine's an energy shotgun, right?
My shotgun's energy, right?
Is that it?
Guys, is it an energy shotgun?
Yeah?
Alright, we're buying this.
We're buying this then.
It's time.
Alright, prep.
Let me rip this arm.
Oh, yeah!
That's double energy.
Wait, maybe I should upgrade my shotgun too.
Wait, can I have a better shotgun?
No, okay.
I cannot.
Alright, we'll just wait.
We'll just wait then.
Alright, let's see.
Model.
Pit space.
Do I not have it?
No, I don't.
Okay, sort.
Alright, let's do one last job.
One last job.
What did I want to get?
Wait, I want to repair all.
Repair equipment.
No, it's fine.
What if I lose it though?
Oh, I guess I might as well.
Alright.
It's time.
One last job.
Tips?
What kind?
Don't worry, I'm very well versed with that.
Yeah!
That's me!
That's me right there.
Do you see that?
Wow, there were cameras there?
Who would have thought?
Okay, I'm going to get insurance for this though.
I'm going to get insurance for my legs and my arm.
They're the only insurance I'll get.
They made a PSA about me ever since I hunted the weatherman.
I'm a menace to society.
Now they don't know when it's going to rain.
It's because of me.
Where did you get those legs?
Wow!
Where did...
Where did I get those legs?
Whoa!
Okay, where am I?
Alright, we're going here.
Oh my god, my legs are so fast.
These legs that I got naturally.
Oh my god, look how fast my legs are that I naturally obtained via hard work and grinding.
Okay, we're going this way.
I don't want to fight a fucking boss.
Thanks guys!
I earned it.
I bought it with my own hard money.
Hahaha!
On me!
I don't want to waste this.
Jesus, they're so strong!
These guys are actually... Oh no!
Oh no, it's raining.
Oh no!
Oh no, it's raining!
No!
No, I forgot to...
I forgot to get repair kits!
Oh, this is bad.
This is actually bad.
Oh no, my legs.
Oh no, I might lose my legs.
I forgot to get repair kits.
No!
I thought I had repair kits.
Where's the cover?
Where's the bridge?
Oh no.
This is my cover now.
We're okay.
Wait, does this not cover me?
Oh, we're not okay.
We're not okay.
Oh no.
No, no, no.
I'm okay.
Oh my god, I might die from rain alone.
I might die from rain alone.
I'm a good person.
Oh.
It's literally acid rain.
What do you mean?
Oh, but he's not new.
Oh my god, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
What exactly is your problem?
I'm sorry!
No!
Oh my god, he's so...
I'm sorry!
He saw me murder!
He tried to kill me!
I'll start the repairs.
He saw...
He's like, hey, hey, stop that.
He's like, wait a minute, stop that.
The guy was like, wait a minute.
Oh no.
We gotta leave.
Oh no!
No!
My legs!
My face!
No!
My cool new legs!
I got hunted down by all of them!
No!
My new shoes!
My shoes!
No!
I lost my legs!
Was it Jake again?
Oh my god!
No way!
It was Jake!
Oh you fucker!
Oh my god, you fucker!
I can't believe Jake took back his legs!
Oh!
No!
He took his back!
He took back his legs!
No!
Did my insurance kick in?
Did it kick in?
Did I get it back?
How do I know if my insurance kicked in?
No!
Oh my god!
I want problems always!
Not so dead pool!
No my girl!
She's making mushrooms!
How do I know if my insurance kicked in?
Oh my god!
I can't collect it yet!
I can't even collect my insurance!
I have to wait an hour!
No!
Alright, I think this is a good point to end it in.
Guys, karma will always get you.
Karma will always find a way to get you no matter what.
I thought I was safe and then Jake came back!
Jake came back and took my legs!
That was fun though.
That was really fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching today's sponsor.
Huge shout out again to...
Jake did not win a 2v1!
I literally was already 1 HP from the other guy that shot me because he saw me kill another person in cold blood and he was like, wait a minute, stop that.
He was like, did I just witness a murder?
Wait, stop that.
He just shot me.
I had to run away.
And then Jake came back at the last second to finish the job.
I was limping.
Blood was dripping from my fucking legs.
I was delusional with like 30% blood loss as I tried to make my escape.
And then Jake rolls up and goes pop pop!
Thank you again to Bandai for the sponsor.
It was great checking out the PvP and the PvP in this game.
So yes, please feel free to check out the pre-order.
Like I said, it's on sale on January 24th.
And the early access is January 17th.
So pre-order now!
Thank you again, Bandai.
I always love the support that you guys give me.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!
Also, check the link in the description below if you want a faster way to see all the stuff that Senuality has.
So yeah, link to Senuality in the description below.
Bye, everybody!
Bye bye!